hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
concept to commercialization
thermo fisher's unique approach to
rapidly advancing your antibody and
protein therapeutics
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
steve lewis senior product manager
gene synthesis and synthetic biology at
thermo fisher scientific
and jeff howe director of scientific and
technical affairs
services at thermo fisher scientific
steve and jeff you may now begin your
presentations
great thank you maria i really
appreciate you
hosting us for today
i will be doing the first half of the
presentation and i'm very excited to be
here for today
first i'd like to talk a little bit just
about thermo fisher in general
we are of course a very large
organization but hopefully today through
this webinar will will help with
navigating it and i really seeing how
small and integrated our company truly
is
we take a lot of pride holistically
across the company in our in our mission
to
enable our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
and today for our presentation we're
going to move into talking about the
agenda
the first half will be primarily about
um
services provided within thermo fisher
scientific for uh early stage discovery
in particular antibodies and we will
talk about why starting with the gene or
gene synthesis is the fastest way to
move ultimately into the clinic
from r d into commercial scale
production
uh so with the agenda here we're going
to start uh really at the beginning of
the therapeutic journey and partnering
with us we're going to talk about uh
optimization of your gene as well as
very advanced next generation gene
synthesis as well as advanced protein
expression techniques
and then also how you move from going
from selecting your candidates
from r d or in the r d environment to
ultimately production from there my
partner jeff will be speaking about
strategies for accelerating your
timeline to clinic
mitigating risk as well as building a
foundation for success and how to get
started with thermo fisher right after
this presentation
so to provide a little bit of context
thermo fisher scientific has been
working in the infectious diseases world
for for quite a long time and we wanted
to start here in terms of providing
context for uh today's presentation
because we have a long history working
within uh infectious disease uh starting
in 2000
we had a very early infectious disease
response
effort that we worked on in terms of hiv
all the way through the mid 2000s and
all the way to today and of course you
can read the whole timeline and if
you're watching this as a recorded
presentation you can pause it um and
take a look at all of the different
details that we've been working on for
more than 20 years in this space um but
i'd like to highlight 2020 and 2021
where we really did have an impact a
significant impact partnering with many
companies around the world in terms of
our response to stars kobe 2.
this was a very rapid and very serious
and very interesting time
not not just for us in the biotech space
but really globally and it's very
challenging and also rewarding to work
on a lot of these early stage activities
in terms of pandemic response
and so if you have any questions about
some of our activities in that space or
how we contributed to
the
development of some of the vaccines and
therapeutics as an organization we'd be
happy to talk about that we also have
some materials that we'd be happy to
send after this presentation
to explain a bit more in depth related
to how we've worked
toward developing critical vaccines at
unprecedented velocities
so for today
we're going to start really talking
about the early steps of therapeutics
and vaccine development starting with
the early stage discovery and research
through development clinical trials and
then ultimately commercial scale
production as i mentioned earlier thermo
fisher of course is a large organization
but today our focus for our webinar is
really to show how you can go from idea
all the way through commercial
production in a relatively seamless way
working with our with our groups in the
world in thermo fisher scientific
and for the first part of today we are
going to focus on uh the early discovery
and research
aspect as well as development before
moving into
the clinical trials aspect as well as
commercial
production with our partner jeff
so today starting in
the early discovery and research we
really focus on the idea of using
recombinant dna based just on sequence
information at the very beginning to
optimize your protein production
within our production organization we do
have the ability to rapidly create dna
from a de novo gene synthesis processes
but believe it or not we actually start
in a digital way we start with a
proprietary algorithm that really helps
us to optimize the gene expression
uh or the protein expression resulting
from your gene synthesis
and so i'll talk about some of those
services today but in particular i'd
like to start by talking about the
discovery workflow
what you're seeing on the screen is what
we believe to be a very reasonable
timeline for starting at the r d scale
or producing what we refer to as
research use only uh targets for protein
production
and so we start on the left at the
project design level where we really
begin with just the electronic sequence
design
going through optimizing the the gene
ultimately to result in higher yields of
protein production
and then we can actually do the
dna synthesis as part of that and we
will do the prototyping in-house and
send you your
gene of desire and
if you'd like we can actually take it
all the way through
uh sub-cloning plasmid production as
well as proteins and at any step along
the way at any any point in this
timeline you really do have the ability
to choose what's relevant to your
organization and your needs at a given
time you don't need to go through the
entire process to work with with our
group you can truly pick which aspects
of this continuum that are most relevant
for you at the time of project design
and so
for us today the
the items that are highlighted in red
gene optimization gene synthesis and
proteins are the ones that we're going
to be focusing on uh to in particular
talk about how you can move from r d to
production in the fastest way possible
first just for a little bit of context
you have
in the protein expression space
very popular host systems that are used
for expression and so you can do cell
free expression which does not have any
uh kind of living components as
associated with it
you can do bacterial expression uh
through
e coli you can do yeast expression
insect expression or mammalian
expression and we'll talk about uh
primarily the complex proteins that you
can make via
mammalian expression and we will talk
about how we view that within our
organization
to ultimately provide you with the
highest quality gene
proteins developed from genes in the
fastest amount of time
so as i mentioned starting out with the
mammalian cell lines that are typically
used for protein expression particularly
in therapeutic therapeutics development
you have two that are uh the most common
here the hex 293 or the human embryonic
kidney cells and tro cells the chinese
hamster ovary cells and the benefits of
mammalian cell lines is that you have
the ability to really
do post-translational modifications uh
as it compares to using another type of
uh
expression system and that's really
important when you're thinking about
developing uh proteins like monoclonal
antibodies or
by specific or try specific uh
applications because uh the reality is
the mammalian cell lines are the way to
go in terms of getting the highest yield
in uh the fastest amount of time at the
highest quality and
different cells whether it's the hex 293
or cho cells
have different uses at different times
and we have that flexibility within our
organization to be able to one not only
offer both but two
as an outsourced service we will also
make recommendations about which ones to
go through for that optimal protein
expression
and so uh in terms of transfection
strategies uh we
have a couple of options that that you
can use here within our gene arts
services and gene art is the name of our
organization who really focuses on that
rnd
range
of protein expression from gene to
protein
and so
our our approach to it from a strategic
perspective is to have transient
expression for 4-14 days which is how
long it can ultimately take depending on
the sequence that you are trying to
design and then ultimately express you
go through a high efficiency
transfection as part of the process uh
through expression and then ultimately
protein production
uh so that's very fast right and we're
trying to talk about the difference here
between what is transient expression
compared to what is stable expression
stable expression really takes uh months
in a lot of cases you're trying to get a
stable cell line at the end of your
process so that you can ultimately in a
reproducible and scalable way uh make
the protein that you're trying to make
as as your target on
various scales and timelines at
different times of of the project that
you have in mind so to kind of summarize
the way that i like to think about
transient expression versus stable
expression is that transient expression
is really when
you have a lot of squishiness or a lot
of uncertainty around kind of what your
gene sequence is and how it's going to
express when it gets into a host cell
system
and then
after that
if you find a candidate that's kind of
working or you find a sequence
and ultimately clone and then plasmid
that works for you and works at various
scales because at gene art we can scale
up from
24 well plates all the way up to 25
liter production scales at the higher
end you really do start to get a greater
sense of okay here's what stable cell
line development would look like and
that can take months and this really
truly isn't comparing the two it really
is that transient expression in a way
from our perspective precedes that
stable cell line development and the
fastest way to do it when working with
our group gene art services is to go
through our outsourced transient
expression workflow which can be as
quick as four days or as long as 14 days
depending on the sequence and the
approach to actually doing the
expression
so
to kind of summarize at the very
beginning jean art will be there for
most of the uncertainty that's that's
where we specialize is when you don't
know what's going to happen call gene r
that that is definitely where we excel
in that transient protein expression
space
now
uh focusing on the discovery workflow
here we're going to start at the very
beginning right going from project
design through gene optimization and
then ultimately to
proteins at the very end of the process
but let's start right at the very
beginning
when
you are
starting off we at gene art will ask you
to send us a sequence associated with
what you are trying to ultimately
express
we have a proprietary patented algorithm
known as gene optimizer
it's our technology that really takes
into account
many parameters to optimize the
mammalian coding region and this allows
us to optimize
expression to
result in the highest yields that you
can you can get right now today we're
very excited about this uh
unique process that we have to
optimizing gene sequences and when
coupled with our production processes
we've seen very strong increases in
terms of yield
resulting from the expression that that
we do
following the optimization
and to talk a bit about uh really just
our world-class performance in this
regard we have a couple of studies that
have been published
and we can get access to them and you
can actually just look them up as well
they're they're available but if you
need a link feel free to reach out to
your thermo fisher partner to be able to
receive a copy
we
have basically compared within this
study
kinase protein expression and our gene
optimizer software consistently provided
higher expression levels compared to the
wild type gene
as high as 200 percent and as low as 25
expression
we have a very high reliability with
this algorithm it's very unique we have
some really talented folks within our r
d organization who worked very very hard
at the molecular level to really
understand what makes sense when you're
building an algorithm to optimize that
protein expression
so
for those
those proteins that were tested in this
study the technology did provide the the
best results out of out of the different
studies and uh no other optimization
algorithm and that's what you can see in
the one two three four five in in each
of the studies uh showed consistent
results um
and you can see in the paper here
the gene art sections uh just exactly
how much the express the optimization
how much of an impact the optimization
actually had and it truly does
outperform all other algorithms on the
market today
this is a selected uh slide from another
study that we that we posted
as well or we published as well
where we looked at different protein
expression types so the last one will
focus primarily on kinase proteins but
this really is a study that was done
very in-depth to demonstrate that
different types of proteins also benefit
from being optimized through the gene
optimizer
whether it's transcription factors to
ribosomal proteins the membrane proteins
the cytokines you can see the amount of
increase that the optimized gene
resulted in compared to the wild type
and it's it's pretty impressive um even
in situations when you are let's say not
with the wild type getting any
expression at all if you look at the
bottom one the cytokines uh in that
particular case the il-2
only expressed in the event of the
optimization uh in terms of relative
expression and and that's just a
testament to how powerful the gene
optimizer algorithm truly is uh within
the gene art environment and then as i
mentioned when it's coupled with our
production processes you're truly
getting the highest chance of the best
yield
that you can get at the highest quality
as well
so moving into a poll question here
if you do have a de novo gene synthesis
project that is currently in process
whether you're doing it in-house or
outsourced to another provider
when do you anticipate you'll require
protein production services
give it a couple more seconds to answer
all right great
and now that we've done that poll
question i'd like to move into talking
about the synthesis and expression uh
part of our presentation again staying
within the the gene genard family within
thermo fisher scientific we're moving on
to really that next step the actual
synthesis itself now that that your
genes have been optimized
so we perform really next generation
gene synthesis with within our thermo
fisher scientific gene art group we of
course as we mentioned started out with
gene optimization through
basically bioinformatics and
what today would be considered machine
learning processes
you move into oligosynthesis
then gene assembly then cloning
sequencing and final documentation
uh everything i just went over really
truly is a sequential process and the
process that we follow within our group
to make sure that you're ending up with
not just ex
a cloned gene but we're really verifying
it we're making sure that
you are getting increased reliability
even with the shorter turnaround time
that that were
that we're able to achieve through our
processes in-house
we
are able to do very high throughput
that's that's something that's fairly uh
impressive at least from my perspective
in in terms of our production partners
at our manufacturing site they're very
fast they've been doing this for 20
years and
we have a really excellent team who not
only takes the time to do the production
but will also work to the point that
they can troubleshoot things that we do
protein production all day every day and
that's a unique thing about this team
they're very very experienced and they
are able to really
go from that optimized algorithm to the
express gene and then uh or excuse me to
the to the gene synthesis and then
the clone gene and making sure that if
there are any troubles along the way
that we will do our due diligence to
make sure that you are getting the
highest sequence accuracy uh possible
and so all of these things combined
doing all of that in-house especially
starting with the gene synthesis itself
um it really allows you to go okay
ultimately at the end of my project i'm
trying to get an express
express protein antibody whatever it is
and you start to wonder okay well how
can i increase my chances for the
highest yield possible and that's what
we mean by next generation gene
synthesis from our perspective is really
starting at the electronic level or the
the digital uh from a digital
perspective where you optimize the
sequence before even starting with any
of the biology and then after that gene
synthesis you have the ability to move
into bioproduction with a bit more
confidence
and so
after the gene synthesis uh you can
really move into an expression plasmid
and then do actual protein expression as
well um you can see in the box that is
uh has a square around it right now
these are really the next steps in that
process on our way toward protein
production
uh you will go from that clone gene to
an expression plasmid before ultimately
doing the expression as we mentioned
before uh we
really championed that gene optimizer
algorithm to increase your protein yield
from your
expression plasmid
we have a lot of design flexibility in
how you want to do your plasmid
preparation
which is very high quality and we do it
all in house and that's the great thing
about working with the with the gene art
group within thermo fisher scientific is
because you're starting your journey
with the same group
all the way up to getting that protein
expression step done along the way you
can have full control over how your
process is going so starting from the
sequence like i had already mentioned
all the way through at this point the
expression plasmid or the plasma
preparation gives you that ability to
have uniquely full control as opposed to
if you were to send in your clone genes
to
another provider which you may not have
control over the different steps of the
process one unique thing about the jnr
group is because we do all of these
services in-house for our partners that
provides the unique ability to control
the different aspects of the process as
you progress through it
and then moving into expression we do
have a number of flexible expression
scales as i mentioned you can go as
small as 96 well plates
for some of our more high throughput or
small scale protein expression
services a lot of our partners will
start in the 100 to 300 milliliter range
in terms of their uh expression after
after the transfection
and as i mentioned when you're looking
toward therapeutic and
ultima and vaccine development
a lot of the time we're going to be
recommending or you're going to be
it
coming to us with those mammalian
expression systems which in this case uh
we really prefer the xp293 and xp cho
but we will also do uh insect
expressions there are certain proteins
that do express uh better within those
sf9 uh insect cells and so that's
something just to be aware of that we
offer it but truly where we excel is in
that transient protein expression of
those mammalian
expression systems
for the right part of the slide i'll let
you read it i'm going to get into more
detail here in a second but our approach
overall
if you look at the bottom the bottom
line there our approach to
bio production is really collaborative
we want to be a strategic partner for
you we have a project management team
who will help you with getting up to
speed our local manufacturing team is
also collated co-located with some of
our project management team and some of
our
sales support and customer support staff
and so that benefit of doing all of it
in-house with jean art is one great way
that you can really drive that
performance through
working with us through that entire
process
so moving into the next poll question
would you like to receive a quote for an
early stage protein production project
i'll give you a few more seconds to
answer
great
and so for the last part of of this
presentation and i really do appreciate
all of your time today uh we are going
to talk about the how we ultimately
increase protein yield through the
actual expression uh and
uh purification processes that we offer
within thermo fisher jean art as i
mentioned it you know there's a lot of
advantages to using the xb293
and ex petro mammalian systems that
really express more protein per cell
that's what everyone's trying to get to
how can i get the highest yield
for
uh you know the in the fastest amount of
time for the lowest amount of cost using
these expression systems is a great way
to do that
and in our case you can see in that
first red box there
using these expression systems will
allow you to have a higher cell density
meaning on a per cell basis you're going
to have higher
productivity and a higher efficiency
transaction as well and you can see that
the protocol is very easy it plugs right
into the five to seven day workflow that
usually uh goes on when it comes to
using the expression systems but what i
want to highlight is
when paired with our gene and vector
optimization as i
mentioned more often than not we are
seeing a 3 to 10x yield improvement
by combining all of these factors and so
you may in certain cases see those
benefits on the right or on the left but
they are enhanced when you combine them
with that gene optimization that i'm
that that i mentioned earlier and it's
more reliable and results in a higher
yield than you would otherwise get with
without doing the gene optimization
and as i mentioned i really encourage
you to take a look at those studies i
highlighted earlier
just a quick bit more explanation in
terms of the
gibbs gibco protein expression systems
they're they're industry leading um it's
likely many of the participants of this
call are very familiar with them uh in
terms of
antibody screening immunogen production
membrane and intracellular protein
expression uh on the left you're going
to see heck 293 the cell-based system
that can have a protein yield up to one
gram per liter
in terms of the yield and on the right
xp cho uh you know really as far as show
cells are concerned another
industry-leading cell-based system
you're going to be getting protein
yields up to 3 grams per liter
which in the bioproduction community
really is uh
toward the upper limit of capability
especially if you're getting them on a
consistent basis like you would be uh
within working with the gene art
framework a lot of the applications for
cho
are some of those more advanced newer
applications like by specifics other
multi-specifics
and then of course antibodies are really
uh you know monoclonal antibodies with
cho cells uh those those are really
popularized workflows that i'm sure many
of you on the call are well aware of and
experienced with today
and just to highlight a bit about the xp
show uh system in terms of the
expression levels uh
you know the tighter in terms of grams
per liter you can see the comparison
versus uh the freestyle show which is
which is another chose system the xb293
and then ultimately the xp chair system
and you'll see just a massive increase
in terms of expression levels um
comparatively with this expedro system
so it's definitely
worth uh using we love it in-house at
gene art we do recommend it for a lot of
our mammalian protein expression
projects and we're
very interested in helping to identify
exactly why
this particular cell uh
expression system is it might be best
for your sequence
but again one of the benefits of working
with gnr is with all that experience we
can do the exact opposite we can also
tell you when not to use it and when
there may be a better alternative um as
well but more often than not this xpto
system we're very
very
big fans of we highly recommend it and
that's something that we're really
really happy to be able to use in-house
within the thermo fisher
family of companies
so
moving on to the
final parts in the r d
scale uh bio production you know you're
going to be interested in purification
and analysis ultimately
we have a number of ways that we can do
purification um we do a lot of them as
you can see in inside that cell um we're
inside that box there um we're very
experienced in this and we feel very
comfortable with it and in terms of our
analysis we have a number of ways some
of our standard processes are the sds
page
nano drop capillary gel electrophoresis
but we can do some other
approaches as well hplc
when it comes to size exclusion
chromatography also we can and have done
with a lot of our partners endotoxin
detection
that is a process that we do get
requested a lot and it's very important
in particular when you're dealing with
for example in certain cases toxic
sequences which can sometimes happen but
are significantly lower risk when you're
starting with that gene optimization
process that i mentioned earlier
so just talking a bit about our
gene to protein services the
purification approaches you can see
everything in the box there um you know
we've got a number of different
chromatography approaches that you can
take to purification we also have
different types of affinity tags but we
also do provide unique customization
options which is uh pretty unique i
would say to
a provider like thermo fisher who does
do a lot of proteins oftentimes on a
high throughput basis we will do
everything from concentration
adjustments
all the way to things that aren't listed
here
like
choosing custom tubes for example
you let us know what your needs are and
we will do our best to absolutely help
you toward making your project go as
smoothly as possible and as quickly as
possible
um and as i
mentioned you know we have a lot of
different ways the filtration and
purification approaches that we have are
not just one
one size fits all
so to speak we understand that every
project is unique and i would go so far
as to say we understand it better
because a lot of times our partners
start at that gene optimization level so
we can see it coming in our production
pipeline and really understand when we
may or may not run into purification
challenges so that's another benefit of
working
for your entire production
workflow at this early discovery stage
with our our gene arts services
here's an example
and this is my second to last slide here
of some of the documentation that you
might receive
early on working with our
gen arts services here we will provide a
certificate of analysis results of the
chromatography
for example
we really want to make sure that you
have a lot of confidence
in in trusting us as your outsourced
provider for transient protein
expression for those early services that
you might be looking at you know it's
one thing to be able to do in-house and
feel like you have control over every
step of the process but we understand
that for some people on this call that
can be cost prohibitive from an
equipment perspective or an investment
perspective and so we want to make
working with gene art really feel like
an extension of your laboratory we want
it to be personalized to you so that we
build that trust over time and really
can grow with you we want to help scale
with you
we you know value every single one of
our customers it's not that we will just
push your proteins through as quickly as
possible we want to treat every single
customer that comes to us with the
respect that we would have doing all of
our projects with our own r d team and
our manufacturing team with all of their
experience they they truly have seen it
all and i can tell you that we're very
proud to talk about how our team cares
so much each and every day about the
projects that they work on
and finally
i'd like to just share a little bit of
information about uh upcoming services
and we actually do provide this on a
pilot basis right now the high
throughput xp show expression and
purification service uh in as fast as 21
days
you can go from sequence
all the way through purified protein
with that analytical report
in either 24 or 96 well played that's
really great for antibody
screening that's something that we have
a lot of partners a lot of the a lot of
the bigger partners that you are
probably very familiar with uh like this
service because it allows them to
explore a number of targets all at once
before ultimately scaling up uh to
higher scales or production volumes and
so you know you can save a lot of time a
lot of money we understand things are
getting smaller uh we understand that
needs are getting faster but maintaining
the higher
quality product that you're used to and
we can say that as we scale down we are
not sacrificing quality in by any means
and this is one new product offering
that we're very excited to have
and offer you today
and so finally i'd like to leave you
before i hand over to my partner jeff
here with this final question would you
like to be contacted by a technical
sales specialist
to understand more about our protein
services
i'll give you a couple more seconds
great
i would like to pass off to my partner
jeff today representing the pharma
services group within thermo fisher
scientific one of our goals today and
reasons for doing this webinar is to
explain how you can really go from that
r d environment ultimately to commercial
scale production and at gene art we're
very proud to be able to take on your
earliest stages of research
really when you're not sure what's going
to happen all the way up to the point
when you feel comfortable to potentially
move into some of those mouth studies or
even ultimately into those clinical
trials and so by working with thermo
fisher scientific you get the benefit of
that early stage transient protein
expression the discovery services and
then jeff is going to speak a bit about
how you can move quickly into clinic
and ultimately to commercial scale
production in one seamless integrated
way within the thermo fisher framework
thank you all
fantastic thanks steve i appreciate the
introduction there
so so i hope everyone's doing well and
uh let's kind of move on uh from the the
r d in into the production of the bio
production side
just want to refocus
the the audience here a little bit uh as
steve kind of presented
uh
going from concept to commercialization
uh it is quite a big endeavor and and we
i just want to try to break this down a
little bit further
on the next slide as you move
out of discovery
and into development and subsequent
stages
so so thermo fisher scientific will
continue to be your partner as you move
out of that phase
and it's really important that we
overcome uh
or once you've overcome some of those
development hurdles
as presented by steve
we we have uh you know the offerings
that are necessary
to get you through that the next stages
now for the rest of this uh presentation
i'll focus on the development section i
will refer to
some of the clinical and commercial
aspects while focused on on some of the
development and elements uh
in in the rest of the slide deck
so so really the key is is to really
leverage the experience of a partner
that can offer a really mature platform
which is built
that allows for easy transition
into a predictable supply chain
so that you are getting the product
if and when you need it
so so this development process uh these
solutions that we're looking for
uh to create this new therapeutic is
really critical um first step in moving
into some of the clinical trials and
commercial production
so
our capabilities um
truly demonstrate an end-to-end service
offering from dna to patient
and and that's really bounded by you
know the foundations of quality um so if
i was to kind of now focus in a little
bit on the process development optima
optimization side once you come out of
that discovery uh piece uh we're really
focused on
uh the process development elements um
of your of your molecule
so that includes things like cell and
development cell culture customization
there could be certain analytical
aspects that that we want to look at
whether it's related to characterization
or some post-translational modifications
or it could be to do with scale up or
tech transfer and
in process monitoring
as well as finally you know generating
some material whether that's it's for
that top study or reference standard
and these are really important factors
as we now embark on this journey
of bioproduction and move into both your
clinical trials and and hopefully into
that commercial launch
at fisher scientific uh especially
specifically within the pharma services
we have these world-class product
capabilities to really drive you there
these capabilities um are definitely
industry-leading um and end-to-end
and and what i mean by that
um
is that
we have been extremely patient-centric
in delivering over 160 molecules
over 20 years of manufacturing
experience
really compressed into
some of the capabilities and service
offerings that that we have to offer
to you as our customers and and
ultimately to our patients
um it's truly end-to-end from
development to manufacturing um
for both ds and dp as you can see on on
this right hand side uh moving from both
material packaging distribution and
ultimately logistics for both clinical
and commercial
and that has really uh
paved the way
for
a lot of success
for some of the molecules that we have
developed
for our customers
so you're not alone when it comes to
evolving
the r d pipelines on biologics
here we see
some market projections
as well as
how we've gotten to this point
uh with with a kga of 11.4 percent right
this pipeline you know continues to be
extremely strong
even during covert times
now while there there is a wild
wide diversity of molecule types
almost 40 percent in that pre
preclinical phase
revolves around monoclonal antibodies
and that's definitely one area that i
want to try to help
target today is around these monoclonal
antibodies
um
when we discuss development
the monoclonal antibodies certainly
provide some baseline on on timeline and
speed
um but with changes in molecular
complexity as you can see here on the
right hand side whether it's things like
adcs or fusion proteins
by specific antibodies
um
we we can use that uh platform that
we've developed for monoclonal
antibodies as a basis
um to further evolve uh the scopes so
that we can explore greater design
spaces um as a way to do risk your cmc
activity so
um so even though this presentation will
focus uh specifically on the the
development and and map side of things
i think the other sixty percent uh we
can certainly tackle with you as well uh
based on again the capabilities and and
experience that we have gathered uh
throughout our 20 years of experience
all right so so then
now that
so let let me pull you back to um to
what we have discussed so far which is
now that you've started your engines on
on discovery and and working with gnar
to generate those first pieces of asset
on the construct and on the molecule
specifically
your next challenges will likely be uh
on that that first in human you know how
quickly can you get into first and human
um and the speed into the clinic as well
as deliver delivering a robust and
productive process into manufacturing so
so as you move along this path as you
get into clinical and commercial uh
there's a certain demand
that that is required and certainly
ensuring that you have a process to meet
those demands
is going to be critical
this now puts the spotlight on on things
like cell and development process
development and potentially that scale
up pilot scale
as as uh paths that will now
fall on the critical timeline if you're
thinking about speed to clinic
all right so then
speed can be uh formulated in a number
of ways uh at them official scientific
our service offerings are are
being modernized with the latest
technology and automation
throughout the various functions of
development we have invested in
advancements in developing new
technology and automation
uh that will
take take us there faster
so for example if we we look at you know
some of the automation and latest
technologies that we have invested in we
start with cell line development a
really targeted approach uh utilizing
microfluidics and oep technology for
single cell cloning
moving into some of the process side
where we have the amber 15
as well as pecan robotics to really
facilitate that both
to facilitate both the upstream
downstream process development
at the smaller scale and then
that the the process is and the cell
line uh i should say is complemented uh
by analytical uh and characterization
foundations through uh the
multi-attribute method and and that's
using a workflow that leverages uh lcms
methodology uh to obtain uh product
quality attributes such as uh glycans
and charge variant data
to now really shine a light on on
product quality as you move into
bio production
if i was to kind of take one example
let's focus back on
the the beacon platform
as mentioned that the beacon platform is
a is a microfluidic system that uses oep
technology so optoelectro positioning um
and it uses light to help us uh with
single cell cloning uh single cell
cloning traditionally is done through
limiting dilution but with the beacon
we're able to now uh use um
now able to seed cells into a
microfluidic device and then sort the
cells
based on monoclonality
if you look at the systematic on the
bottom
the the instrument is on the left with
the
image in the middle showing how we're
using oep to channel cells uh into
what's what's called these nanopins so
channels within the microfluidic device
um and then we're able to assess both
growth and productivity uh over a five
day period
but so this has uh introduced a
significant amount of automation as well
as modernization to the to the way we we
deal with cell line development and to
the way we introduce a cell line
into the bio production pathway
so realizing speed to ind or impd
is not just uh accelerating uh the the
platform
the quick the clinic offering is uh is
our offering to which
has gone through careful
construction and integration
of a number of things certainly the
first one is around the workflows uh
it's around the beacon it's around the
amber systems and the miniaturization
that we're able to to get out of their
workflows
as well as the analytical methods um so
so as we develop the
the molecule and the process uh that
there's understanding of the process
that's required through various
analytical methods
but i think you know what's more
important um is the robustness of that
platform uh with over 80 pd programs
since 2017
um and now a revamped xp choice to os
cell line which i'll i'll talk into lit
i'll speak to a little bit more detail
in subsequent slides is really getting
us to the productivity that that we're
looking for
and then also leveraging the process
development experience that we've had
through those programs
and this is then combined with assessing
risk and you'll hear me talk about risk
throughout this presentation uh which is
really critical as as we
we're thinking about uh moving to that
ind or impd
but so we talk about timelines we talk
about
accelerating we talk about speed so this
is our quick to clinic
2.0 timeline
it's accelerated and optimized start to
finish workflow
that as you can see draws on a number of
parallel activities we have taken a
really careful approach to identifying
what's on the critical timeline
and then optimizing the workflow
accordingly and this is the end product
of that approach
you can see that some assumptions are
made through the workflow but what's
truly impressive is that this is not
just completing a gmp batch
at the end it's integrating the pd
to the tech transfer as well as the gmp
operations and finally
we're able to release your dsmdp within
that time frame
and this is all because we are with you
every step of the way to really get you
closer to that ind or impd submission
so so now i have a poll question for you
so if you have a large molecule in r d
or pre-clinical
when is your ind or impd milestone
give you a couple of seconds to
go through that
hey
so so moving along then having seen
the the timeline i'm sure by now you're
wondering how we addressing some of the
risks um and the with the amount of
concurrent work
uh mitigating predictable risk is
certainly embedded in in this offering
in the quick the clinic offering um and
you know there are three key pieces um
our approach is really leveraging a well
characterized cell line uh which is
coming up next um
that will help reduce inherent risks and
failure points as we move from discovery
to bioproduction
um and then it's it's about advancing
our platforms
so we have invested um heavily in into
developing this platform
that really is able to to pull together
the the critical pieces that you need in
getting you to that ind
well then quickly 2.0 um
has definitely
been focused um on on a
revamped cell line um and that being the
gibco freedom xp s cell line so steve
had mentioned you know some of the work
uh that uh has been done uh through his
group um and and more importantly uh the
the heck 293 cell line as well the xp
cho
being really critical foundations in the
r d
environment in in generating some of
these products and now we've really
turned
the transient system into stable one
certainly for our workflow at the very
beginning where we're doing cloning and
gene synthesis
in some of the plasma prep work
that is supported throughout our gene
art entity
and and really this is
our transition point where we're going
from discovery uh into
bioproduction
uh what's also uh really critical here
is that anything that you learn through
discovery is maintained right whether
it's through vector design or other
things that those are all maintained as
we transition to bioproduction we don't
want to lose any
of the really critical
aspects that you put into
the design of your construct uh through
this initial process so so so this is
really the handshake that you see
going from gnar
into
the farm services
so when we think about the freedom xp os
cell line um it's the same robust cell
line
but there's only gmp banked
that you've used through the transient
system
has been adapted for high density
culture
getting to two by seven
uh to
around two by seven um or two by ten to
seven cells per mill
it's been documented in literature um of
its uh rapid doubling times um as well
as
uh the the ability to be
to produce
a high amount of protein as as you can
see
on your right hand side
definitely in the grams range
between that that three to four
range
and then when we think about uh
the cell line and the stability of the
cell line uh we've seen good stability
across many of the clones that we've
generated
whether it's for mab or recombinant
protein
and certainly we've seen really high
quality and and very active protein uh
where we're looking through some of the
analytical methods um so so so if if you
take one message away from this slide
it's to say that uh the the cell line
the host cell on that you're using for
uh the transient um your transient
operations will be the same cell line
that you use for your stables
now consistent quality between transient
stable clones is really critical
and and i think that
as steve had mentioned
uh certainly for the expert os
system
in the transient format we've seen gram
ranges as demonstrated on the left hand
side we've also seen very comparable
product quality here you see some
n-glycan data
moving from transients to stables with a
400 times increase in scale as well
and certainly
while we see some differences the g0f
still remains uh relatively consistent
throughout
and the final piece to the freedom xp
os is the the regulatory support
information
there is a a master file for this
particular cell line in the form of a
document document
a regulatory package
that provides
the
the information around the cell line the
history the lineage as well as
characterization
um there is uh certainly an application
data package uh that's available um and
then um
the lineage um as mentioned um in
supporting your regulatory filing
so i would like to take another couple
of seconds um to for another poll
question would you like to be contacted
by a sales specialist to learn more
about the quick to clinic solution for
large molecules
hopefully this is an easy one that you
can just click yes or no
give another 10 seconds
all right so so moving along so just a
couple of slides left um
now going through the
and introducing to you the the stable
system the stable xp choice system and
how it fits within quick to clinic
2.0
we've really laid the foundations
for success
for your ind or impd
so hopefully you know you can see that
quick to clinic
is
formulating that the
the pieces that are really critical for
this foundation
where it combines the process the
analytics as well as the scale-up
strategy uh with a really robust cell
line um that is available now to create
your molecule interest
um
you know it's certainly through
um
through some of the slides you you could
see that it's been integrated into our
platform
uh it continues to be royalty free or
exit fee free um and and we we have a
significant body of data around scale-up
solutions uh well beyond your ind and
impd milestones
kind of some from my section up
um
quick to clinic is just that first step
um and and really getting your molecule
uh past the the ind and impd
is that first step in the life
the drug life cycle
i want to highlight here that certainly
pharma services is able to help you go
beyond that
going from both lab to clinic and then
to commercial
so so we have
some additional services which
i'm sure that there will be
opportunities in the future to kind of
share with you
so with that i'll ask you to complete
another poll question uh would you like
to talk talk with a business development
executive about your development and
commercialization goals
again a quick and in easy one so
hopefully
you can click a yes or no to that
question
give you another five seconds
all right
so let me sum it up um and i'll try to
sum up steve's section as well if i can
um
so so as steve presented um you know
partnering with thermofisher scientific
can significantly speed up your
development timelines
starting with gene synthesis is the
fastest way um to screen uh and
to screen those clones to identify the
candidates that's necessary
for that next step of wire production
gnr services
through what steve have presented
can accelerate the protein r d timelines
and really simplify your process
and i think ultimately what i took out
of what steve has said is really help
you come up with a solution
in addressing you know some of the
challenges
as you go through that kind of workflow
now while the speak to clinic is one of
the most critical goals coming out of
discovery
it shouldn't be prioritized at the
expense of other
critical success factors and i hope that
you know that risk-based assessment that
you saw throughout the presentation um
helps uh to to
[Music]
to address that point
and then work with with just like thermo
fisher scientific who can offer seamless
scale-up solutions beyond the ind and
impd milestone
certainly this is
this is really critical
and
we should kind of ensure that
that there is complete end to end
for any molecule
or any drug that you're trying to funnel
through that life cycle approach
and finally a quick to clinic
program
for monoclonal antibodies that's
designed to take you from transfection
to ind in as little as 13 months it's
certainly market leading
and you know we would balance
the risks
to the reward as well
so with that um i'll
move over to that final slide uh just
some contact information or any um any
additional uh information that you need
please reach out
and
with that i want to thank you for
for your attendance uh to this webinar
thank you steve and jeff for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for steve
can we ship clones from another provider
for gene art to perform protein
expression and purification projects
that's a great question the answer is
yes you absolutely can do that one of
the things that we do encourage within
uh gene art services at thermo fisher
scientific is the fact that we can do
the entire continuum from
dna sequence all the way through
expressed
and purified protein in house so you
will get a higher level of service and
likely a higher level of quality as well
by working with us at thermo fisher dean
art from the very beginning
and one thing that we can do as a result
of doing that is at any point in the
process you have the ability to have
better control over everything sometimes
there's a risk in shipping clones and
that there can be
um you know mislabeled tubes there can
be
shipping conditions or packaging that
are not up to par that we don't have any
control over if we receive it in that
way
and if the reason for wanting to do that
revolves around pricing we're more than
happy to discuss options to really
provide you everything that you need
in-house from that sequence design all
the way through the purified protein
so feel free to contact
one of your thermo fisher partners who
you work with and
we'd be more and more than happy to
discuss the different options available
to you
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
this question is for jeff
how are you addressing current
challenges around raw material sourcing
with regards to the quick to clinic
solution
thanks marie um yeah no no doubt this
one's on everyone's mind uh it's
certainly a challenging environment
right now
that said
with this kind of platform approach that
we're taking
there's only a standard set of
single-use components um
and a standard set of resins and media
that that we we would use uh and we're
able to really uh procure those uh well
in advance uh in preparation for the gmp
manufacturing batch
um and and sometimes even uh before uh
prior to
to that signature so so really it
depends on uh
where where we are in terms of you know
the just um the discussions with with uh
contractual items and things like that
but
but you know there's always you know
with with such a
uh changing environment there's there's
always opportunities uh to to go through
and and identify the the critical
uh timeline items that that's stopping
us uh from from moving forward so and
then we're always open for that
discussion so
so that will be my answer to that marie
thank you all right well thank you again
steve and jeff for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye